hey guys happy holidays I'm excited
because this is my first ever holiday
gift guide now this is gonna be a guide
of things that I saw online that I
thought were cool also things that I
might have bought this past year that I
think that you might actually like or
you might want to gift somebody else but
I have a feeling that a lot of times
this is sort of a gift guide of what
you're gonna want to ask for this
holiday season
I also asked you guys on Twitter what
you guys were looking forward to
receiving we're also gifting stay tuned
because I am giving away a Nintendo Wii
U with splatoon and a Gamestop gift card
so I just wanted to kind of give back a
little present for you guys because
you're amazing it awesome and also for
this gift card there's a little
stipulation whoever wins has to promise
me that you will buy yourself something
but you will also buy something for
somebody else is the season cassadee
first up she wants a drone and a g7 X
and a g7 X is the vlogging camera that I
always use as far as the drone goes
that's a pretty awesome gift so if you
do get a drone for Christmas let me know
how it works out for you as far as video
games go there were so many games that
came out this year and some towards the
end of the year that it might be a
difficult decision if you're buying
games for somebody or if you have them
to be getting them for yourself
but Game Stop actually has a really
great deal going on they have $20 off
call of duty black ops three FIFA Madden
rise of the Tomb Raider Forza 6 and rock
band and the Star Wars Battlefront ps4
is $50 off along with an Xbox one so if
you guys are looking for any last-minute
consoles or games game strap is
definitely the way to go for that what I
love about Game Stop is you can go in
there and also find tons of other things
oh I forgot to show you this Edie got me
this controller it's the lunar white
controller and it's also a game strap
exclusive
there's also another option for
controller which is the Xbox one elite
controller and I'm obsessed with this
controller and has these little paddles
in the back so you can sort of flip
those around and remap all the buttons
to sort of suit your playing style it's
really cool but if you just want the
basic controller definitely check out
the lunar white it was beautiful and if
you're in the Nintendo games one of my
favorites became out this year was
splatoon you might have saw this really
fun splatoon obstacle course
that I did a long time ago with Nintendo
before it came out but the game is so
much fun and it's one of those things
where I feel like a lot of games say
that they're fun for all ages but this
game is actually fun for all ages I've
seen kids enjoying it I've seen adults
playing it
and it's sort of this third-person
shooter game we're shooting ink all over
the map and you basically want to try to
cover the arena if you your color ink as
much as possible and it's so much fun to
play with friends play on lines it's
definitely gonna be a holiday game that
I'm gonna be playing with my sister's
also some splatoon amiibo that you can
get that will work with Mario maker but
is also another fun game one of those
games that I think anybody can enjoy
whether you like creating Mario maker
levels or you like playing the levels
that other people created other fun game
for to guests is Hannibal browsing happy
home designer it so pretty much you're
just building the houses in the rooms
and kind of decorating with all the
items and I had so much fun playing this
game and it also comes with little
amiibo cards so you can get those for
people who might already have the game
dead wants a new microphone I saw
recently the blue microphone has
released a white version of their Yeti
microphone and I love using that for
recording gameplay and it's probably one
of my favorite microphones that's easily
accessible because it's USB plug it in
it works pretty much without fail but
there's also another microphone by Audio
Technica it's USB but it'll also plug
into your iPhone it's this massive
microphone but you can get amazing audio
quality or it into your phone it's a
little bit of overkill but I thought it
was pretty cool at Amazon echo all right
an emoji pillow you could not go wrong
with an emoji pillows go to throw boy
just get them up poop emoji and they
will be happy and whilst they have no
sense of humor or maybe you get a new
friend add the products every watch I've
had pro that's a big list you've got
there you know what the best joke would
be is to buy somebody an Apple pencil it
doesn't have an iPad pro don't do that
that's that's very cruel but you could
give them a new Apple TV those just came
out a few months ago so I think that's a
pretty good gift Oh somebody actually so
that they want tickets to VidCon or
streamcon next year that's a really good
idea I never even thought about that if
there's somebody you know that one's a
bit a bit Connor streamcon or some other
event even concert tickets that's a good
idea
Oh Brendan said to hang out with me
here's to sweet get yourself a new Star
Wars onesie I'm going to need to find
the Star Wars one of these Lego sets you
cannot go wrong with LEGO sets there are
so many to choose from just make sure if
you're getting a Lego set for a small
child that it's not one of the difficult
ones because you will have angry parents
and you'll have upset children because
they won't be able to complete their
Lego set Tom is suggesting a Fuji
smartphone printer
these are actually really cool because I
bought one earlier this year and I know
if you guys remember how obsessed I was
the little polaroid pictures everyone
seemed to be so obsessed with those but
you didn't want to have to carry around
another camera especially when most of
the photos end up being on your phone or
another camera but the little printer
just uses the film that you would be
putting into the other camera and it'll
print it right from your phone with
Bluetooth right stocking stuffer good
idea Tom also from my blog post I made a
video on this the flora where does the
cefiro bb-8 droid which you control on
your phone so it's like a little bb-8
and he just kind of rolls around your
floor and you can control them with your
smartphone
super cute another fun game Lego
dimensions so if you know somebody who
already has lego dimensions maybe go and
investigate what both characters they
have and give them something they don't
have well or recently came out as well
and there's so much fun fallout 4 swag
online so if you know someone who's a
pull-up for a fan you peter get them the
game or you could get them one of the
pip-boy editions and you put your phone
in it it's pretty neat and I promise you
anything for a fan will be super excited
about it it's really neat the flux
capacitor USB car charger so if you know
somebody who might need to charge their
phone in the car perfect stocking
stuffer John says the Canon video
creator kit which is amazing because it
comes with the t2i a lens of Mike it
basically is everything that you're
going to need to start vlogging and see
a ton of people who are wanting the
hoverboards for Christmas but be careful
because they are catching on fire not a
good thing also probably one of the best
gifts that you could get anyone or
yourself is my book Wang Wang pilcrow
Phillips hue lights I'm such a huge fan
of Phillips hue lights if you've ever
seen those before I have them all in my
office and I just hit some different
buttons on my phone I'm an app and it
changes the colors turns them off turn
them on and they're all controlled by
basically my phone let me know in the
comments below things that you guys are
looking forward to or what you're asking
for this holiday season or what you plan
on getting your friends and family also
be sure to check out my blog for a more
extensive list of gift items and for
information on how to get the gift card
and the Nintendo WiiU
I love you guys happy holidays I'll see
you soon bye so let's turn these into
banana bread I've already got my
ingredients set up before me let me see
what we need to do first